mesdames et messieurs de la presse je
vous remercie de votre présence et vous
adresse mes voeux les meilleurs pour
2016 que cette année vous apporte toutes
les satisfactions que vous pouvez
souhaiter à titre personnel d'abord et
dans l'exercice de votre métier bien
entendu
vous me verrez peut cette année nous
aurons peu d'occasions de nous
rencontrer directement parce que j'irai
cette année avant de lancer ma campagne
présidentielle début 2017 et pas avant
au contact direct des français j'ai en
effet l'intention de passer 2016 dans la
plus grande proximité possible avec
notre peuple
j'ai envie de l'écouter encore davantage
j'ai besoin de discuter avec toutes ses
composantes toutes ses forces vives tous
ses métiers et avec les habitants de
tous les territoires